[Applaus]
[Musik]
das jahr 2021 die zu ende und für visual
politik.de war es ein sehr erfolgreiches
jahr in diesem jahr sich die zahl
unserer abonnenten verachtfacht und
wiedergabe zeit unserer videos gar 64
macht all das wäre ohne euch unsere fans
und zuschauer nicht möglich gewesen
diese tollen zahlen und aller zuspruch
und engagement in den kommentaren sind
uns eine riesen motivation weiter videos
für euch zu drehen darüber hinaus haben
uns rund 250 von euch eine spende
zukommen lassen dass wir noch mal ein
extra großes dankeschön allerdings so
wollten wir es angesichts dieses
außergewöhnlichen kommentar sei es nicht
bei schönen worten belassen da hat mir
versprochen jede eurer spenden mehr und
bessere videos zu stecken und heute wird
geliefert ja so dass heutige bonus video
sind die 250 edlen finanziellen
unterstützer unseres kanals
verantwortlich also vergesst bitte nicht
ihnen allen in den kommentaren dank
auszusprechen und falls ihr selbst dazu
beitragen wollen dass es noch mehr bonus
videos gibt der spenden link befindet
sich wie immer in der beschreibung unter
diesem video wir hoffen dass euch unsere
heutige spezial folge gefällt denn wir
möchten mit ihr eine neue jährliche
tradition begründen die visual politik
ntr wars das heißt von nun an wird euch
der weihnachtsmann hier auf diese
politik als kleines geschenk eine
abrechnung mit jenen politikern bringen
die uns im zu ende gegangenen jahr am
meisten enttäuscht haben wohl genau das
hat es sich nicht unbedingt um die
absolut schlechtesten politiker des
jahres sei also nicht überrascht werden
auf unserer liste weder kino und nicolas
module oder ein anderer tyrann zu finden
ist natürlich hätten es all diese
figuren verdient eine ordentliche
abreibung zu bekommen aber seien wir
ehrlich keiner von ihnen kann uns noch
persönlich enttäuschenden wir haben
sowieso nichts gutes von ihnen erwartet
nein wie visual politik ntfs richten
sich an jene politiker von denen wir
zumindest etwas gutes erwartet hätten
und die unserem ende jedoch bitter
enttäuscht haben
[Musik]
und glaubt mir die auswahl zu treffen
war nicht einfach wenn man bedenkt was
für krasse dinge dieses jahr abgegangen
sind während wir 2020 noch befürchteten
dass die welt politische landschaft zu
einer dystopie allein 1984 verkommen
würde scheint es dieses jahr tatsächlich
so sein als würden wir in einer staffel
big brother leben der ein skript direkt
aus der feder eines kommt vielleicht
hast du es schon vergessen das war das
jahr 2000 als sonst ich bekam mit dem
sturm einiger john fans auf das kapitol
in washington dc es mich irgendwie an
eine folge von black mirror erinnerte
die von den autoren der sitcom wie
office geschrieben wurde außerdem sahen
wir wie der weißrussische diktator
alexander lukaschenko migranten aus dem
nahen osten als politische waffe
einsetzte in einer politischen episode
die so absurd war dass sie wie eine
komödie wirkte wenn sie nicht so real
gewesen wäre
überall auf der welt haben wir gesehen
wie es für politiker inmitten immer
stärker werdender spaltung lagerdenken
und identitätspolitik immer schwieriger
geworden ist stabile
regierungsmehrheiten zu finden welche
die mehrheit der wähler repräsentieren
und vereinen würden aber natürlich sind
die politiker selbst auch an diesen
entwicklungen schuld viele profitieren
von ihnen auf ungeheure weise und
fördern sie daher mal offen mal
heuchlerisch verdeckt denn wenn eine
solche parasitäre masche für eine
gewisse kritische masse an machtmenschen
und opportunisten mal richtig gut
funktioniert ist die erfolg kaum noch
aufzuhalten selbst wenn sie der
gesellschaft insgesamt noch so sehr
schadet dafür braucht übrigens keine
verschwörung im oder masterpläne es
handelt sich um einen leider leider über
außen natürlichen mechanismus der schon
unzählige zivilisationen in den abgrund
geführt hat jeder ägyptologe und als
historiker kann ein liedchen davon
singen mit anderen worten für das
kommende jahr gibt es wenig grund für
optimismus und das sind keine leeren
worte du weißt dass wir bei visual
politik immer gerne auch auf die
positive seite der dinge verweisen wenn
wir einen politiker oder eine regierung
applaudieren können tun wir das
vorbehaltlos aber so wie die dinge lagen
war es dieses jahr schwierig gute
nachrichten zu überbringen eine liste
mit nur drei schlechten politikern zu
erstellen war schon fast ein ding der
unmöglichkeit
nun ja wir haben uns trotzdem
zusammengerissen denn wie gesagt wird
das alljährliche motto dieser reihe
aller schlechten dinge sind drei holt
also euer popcorn macht es euch
gemütlich bei dieser visuellen politik
folge mit überlänge glaubt mir heute
wird es nicht bis zum ende lohnen denn
kein auge trocken bleiben was immer ich
damit auch meine lasst uns also loslegen
der allererste visual politikentwurf
überhaupt geht an
[Musik]
wer bist du alt politiker
2021 joe biden am 20 januar wurde josef
wernet beiden junior besser bekannt als
joe biden als präsident der usa
vereidigt er wurde der 46 zu präsident
der vereinigten staaten und kann vor
allem mit einer mission an die macht die
konfliktreiche politische phase der
jockeys und ins internationale image der
vereinigten staaten zu verbessern und
die amerikanische gesellschaft wieder zu
vereinen seitdem hat der amerikanische
präsident jedoch trotz der relativ
kurzen zeit verstrichen ist so viele
fehler gemacht dass er einen anti preis
mehr als verdient hat der erste
riesenflop beiden es braucht wohl kaum
eine erklärung er wird als das vietnam
der millennials in die geschichte
eingehen
[Musik]
ganz genau der abzug aus afghanistan war
ein kolossales desaster na klar es
stimmt dass man einen krieg nie auf
fröhliche und feierliche weise verliert
und natürlich hatte die sich schon lange
abzeichnende niederlage nichts mit
diesen speziellen präsidenten zu tun
aber niemand absolute niemand konnte
sich das chaos den pessimismus und den
mangel an kontrolle vorstellen die den
abzug der us truppen unter beiden
begleiteten die dinge liefen so schief
dass tausende von us-soldaten tage lang
praktisch geiseln der taliban waren die
taliban waren es übrigens welche die
frist für den abzug der usa gesetzt
haben und nicht nur das nach 20 jahren
ist die situation in der die amerikaner
das land hinterlassen haben einfach nur
schrecklich
[Musik]
die macht liegt in den händen ultra
religiöser fanatiker millionen von
menschen müssen hungern frauen werden
wieder absolut unterdrückt und sogar
massenhinrichtungen an gegnern der neuen
machthaber gehören zum alltag die
taliban haben also so ziemlich jedes
versprechen der menschlichkeit gebrochen
auf welches sich beiden aber auch sein
vorgänger james verlassen hatten die
vereinten nationen selbst haben bereits
mehr als 100 hinrichtung von ehemaligen
kollaborateuren und beamten der früheren
von den usa unterstützten afghanischen
regierung zugegeben die un schlägt alarm
wegen außergerichtliche tötungen in
afghanistan durch die taliban aus
welchem blickwinkel man ist auch
betrachten mag der abzug aus afghanistan
war ein echter viel schlag ein
monumentaler fehlschlag ein desaster
aber das ist noch nicht alles denn
afghanistan ist nicht der einzige felder
beiden regierung es gibt auch etwas dass
einige bereits beiden flaschen nennen
wir sprechen von einer großen diskrepanz
zwischen der wirtschaftlichen situation
und der von der regierung geförderte
politik so erreichte die inflation in
den vereinigten staaten im november den
höchsten stand seit 40 jahren die preise
stiegen im vergleich zum
vorjahreszeitraum um 6,8 prozent es sind
zwar noch keine argentinischen
verhältnisse aber du wirst mir zustimmen
dass wir uns inmitten einer hochgradig
riskanten lage befinden die frage ist
also was unternimmt beiden nun im grunde
ist er immer mehr öl ins feuer anfang
des jahres unterzeichnete er das zweite
1,9 billionen dollar corona
rettungspaket im mai stellte er seine
grundzüge der wirtschaftspolitik vor die
zum beispiel vorsehen dass die
öffentlichen ausgaben im verhältnis zum
bip bis zu beginn des nächsten
jahrzehnts auf den höchsten stand seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg steigen werden und
der aktuelle haushaltsplan für 2022 die
bereits ausgabenerhöhungen in fast allen
bereichen vor
mitte november unterzeichnet er dann das
1 2 billionen dollar schwere sogenannte
infrastrukturprogramm von denen jedoch
nur ein bruchteil tatsächlich in die
infrastruktur investiert wird in
wahrheit handelt es sich um einen
billionen etikettenschwindel von den der
großteil in konsumausgaben und
politische geschenke fließt wir haben
darüber ein eigenes video gemacht und
als ob das nicht genug wäre treibt ja
jetzt obendrein noch 1 2 billionen
dollar wohlfahrts mega projekt voran
klar wenn wir schon dabei sind die
zukunft unserer kinder zu verbrennen
dann aber ordentlich hatte ich fest
insgesamt rechnet beiden damit dass die
staatsverschuldung des bundes in den
nächsten zehn jahren und mindestens 17
billionen dollar ansteigen wird warum
mir das für fatal halten nun denkt man
einen moment darüber nach du magst
staatliche ausgaben anreize mehr oder
weniger mögen als ich aber diesen weg
einzuschlagen wenn die wirtschaft wächst
ist millionen von offenen stellen gibt
und die inflation in die höhe schießt
ich weiß nicht das könnte man schon fast
als totaler nonsens bezeichnet etwas was
gegen jede volkswirtschaftliche logik
geht das ist fast schon auf dem level
von erdogans gaga politik aller
zinserhöhungen treiben die inflation an
tja und trotzdem ist es genau das was
beiden und sein team gerade jetzt tun
aber seid vorsichtig denn wir reden hier
nicht nur über staatliche ausgaben
orgien in sachen energie ist es zum
beispiel mehr oder weniger die gleiche
geschichte die öl und gaspreise sind in
die höhe geschnellt und beiden fordert
wie verrückt dass die opec die
produktion erhöhen soll aber was macht
er eigentlich in den usa nun genau das
gegenteil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit beiden im weißen haus sitzt hat die
regierung alle neuen konzessionen zur
förderung von gas oder erdöl ausgesetzt
die förderung im nordosten alaskas wurde
gestoppt und die genehmigung zum bau
einer pipeline mit alberta kanada welche
die usa mit fast einer million barrel öl
pro tag versorgung sollte wurde
widerrufen und was soll ich sagen es
scheint eben ein bisschen heuchlerisch
zu sein auf der einen seite den öl- und
gasindustrie im eigenen land zu
behindern wo es nur geht und auf der
anderen seite zu fordern dass die opec
die produktion erhöht das ergebnis eine
schwere energiekrise explodierende
preise und alle leiden darunter die
wirtschaft und die bürger und dann ja es
ist schön und gut die energiewende und
saubere technologien zu fördern aber es
gibt keinen grund dies auf eine weise zu
tun die den vorstand und das wohlergehen
von familien zerstört ganz zu schweigen
wenn du alle bestraft und dann die
ölscheichs am persischen golf bitte ist
ihr zu hilfe zu kommen und dir so viel
öl wie möglich zu verkaufen könnte
dahinter vielleicht die nicht ganz offen
ausgesprochene agenda stehen die
heimischen ölproduzenten dafür zu
bestrafen dass im wahlkampf auf der
seite der charts standen das ist doch
gelinde gesagt einfach nur noch
verwerflich wenn das du nicht auch aber
warten denn wir sind noch nicht fertig
mit als ob das alles nicht schon genug
wäre sehen beiden und traf jetzt auch
noch so aus wie die schrecklichen zu
willigen des globalen protektionismus
warum nun der neue präsident hat weder
die versprochene chance zurückgenommen
sondern im gegenteil auch noch einige
eigene handelskriege losgetreten zum
beispiel hat er den holz krieg mit
kanada aufgenommen und die zelle einfach
nur verdoppeln auch wer sein land nicht
wieder in das cpp einbinden das
pazifische handelsabkommen das in aller
munde ist und dem sogar länder wie
großbritannien china und taiwan
beitreten wollen selbst das aber ist nur
die spitze des riesigen eisbergs und
flops die joe biden in nur einem jahr
präsidentschaft anzuhäufen geschafft hat
ganz zu schweigen von seiner
vize-präsidenten kamera harris welche
mitunter 28 trotzdem zustimmungsquote in
der bevölkerung die unbeliebteste
vizepräsidentin aller zeiten ist und das
ist schon ein verdammt großes standbein
so starken konkurrenten mit dem hyper
korrupten kriegstreiber dick cheney und
dem dümmlich irrlichternden quail falls
sie nicht wisst wer denkt wer war dieser
mann hat während seiner amtszeit als
vizepräsident einen unfreiwilligen
schenkelklopfer nach dem anderen
produziert beispiel gefällig der
republikanischen partei wird immer
vorgeworfen die armen im stich zu lassen
aber es ist genau anders warum die armen
sind selbst schuld weil sie und ihre
stimmen geben doch denn quelle hat unter
george bush bedient und das ist lange
lange her heute befinden wir uns unter
joe biden und seiner vocal vertreterin
kamera harris auf einem ganz neuen level
der menschenverachtung arroganz und
verblödung und schon allein deswegen ist
dieses duo einer der drei gewinner des
visual politik 2021 ntr wort glückwunsch
obwohl glückwunsch nicht ganz das
richtige wort ist wie wär's damit lieber
job wenn du dir einen platz im erlesenen
club der schlechtesten präsidenten der
usa auf jeden fall sichern willst dass
du dann kurz einfach nur nicht ändern
aber jetzt kommen wir ganz schnell zu
unserer zweiten preisträgerin
[Musik]
der visual politik ntr wort 2021 ursula
von der leyen für alle die ursula
gertrud von der leyen nicht kennen wir
reden hier über die präsidenten der
europäischen kommission also nichts
geringeres als das europäische
produktion beiden und wieso hat uns die
ehemalige deutsche familie arbeiten und
verteidigungsministerin so sehr in ihrer
neuen rolle in brüssel enttäuscht dass
wir einen entega wort verleihen mussten
nun dafür gibt es viele gründe aber
einer sticht aus ihnen hervor ihre
desaströse wirtschaftspolitik die wir in
zwei worten zusammenfassen können über
bürokratische ausgaben orgien man könnte
sagen das ist das gegenteil von allem
darstellt wofür wir hier bei visual
politik einstehen mit anderen worten
wenn es von der leyens ziel ist ein
europa zu schaffen indem ist für
innovative unternehmen unmöglich ist zu
wachsen oder gar erst zu entstehen in
dem sich alimentierte bürokraten fernab
von den bürgern das gesamte
wirtschaftsgefüge kontrollieren und
letzterer dann eine schuldenkrise ganz
neuen ausmaßes auslösen dürfen dann
macht von allein einen ausgezeichneten
job aber da wir eher fans freiheitlicher
florierender volkswirtschaften und
fiskalischer verantwortung sind ist uns
von der leyen so willkommen diffus bild
und ich weiß dass einige von euch sage
werden hast du vielleicht etwas anderes
erwartet wenn es eine sache gibt die
brüsseler politiker kennzeichnet dann
ist es ihre bedingungslose liebe zu mehr
vorschriften mehr bürokratie mehr
subventionen und mehr steuern nicht wahr
nein bei all den negativen erfahrungen
die wir mit dem moloch eu machen mussten
lehnen wir es grundsätzlich ab diese
fatalistische sichtweise des
europäischen projekts als eine
natürliche gesetzmäßigkeit zu
akzeptieren nein ein vereinigtes europa
muss auch anders gehen wir müssen nur
alle stärker dafür kämpfen
denkt mal darüber nach von der leyen ist
doch eigentlich eine mitterechts
politikerin aus deutschland als tochter
des langjährigen niedersächsischen cdu
ministerpräsidenten ernst albrecht
sollte sie doch finanzpolitische
verantwortung mit der muttermilch
aufgesogen haben das heißt solide zu
wirtschaften der freien entfaltung von
forschung und wirtschaft eine stabile
grundlage zu bieten und langfristig
nicht mehr auszugeben als man einnimmt
langfristig zu denken und korruption und
verschwendung zu bekämpfen zumindest
hätten dies die meisten bürger in den
anderen eu staaten erwartet für sie sind
die deutschen noch immer die größten
verfechter der sparsamkeit und
bodenständigkeit schließlich sind dies
die hauptgründe warum deutschland zur
wirtschaftlichen lokomotive des
kontinents geworden ist das ist es was
sie von jemandem wie ursula von der
leyen erwartet haben was sie uns jedoch
gebracht hat ist das hier
staats und regierungschefs einigen sich
auf 1,82 billionen euro haushalts und
corona sanierungspaket genau hier haben
wir sie die europäische fassung der
hyper bürokratischen ausgaben orgie und
machte einen moment denn zudem 1,8
billionen euro kommen noch einmal 500
milliarden euro an hilfen für
unternehmen in zug insgesamt wird
brüssel mehr als zwei billionen euro
ausgeben um sich von den zerstörerischen
maßnahmen gegen die verbreitung des
corona die ruß zu erholen was ja auch
nicht sonderlich geklappt hat
das ist eine so astronomisch große zahl
dass es schon fast beängstigend ist sie
vor sich zu haben und wofür soll all
dieses geld ausgegeben werden nun auf
dem papier will von der leyen die
europäische wirtschaft in eine grüne
nachhaltige digitale dynamische und 2.0
wirtschaft verwandeln es wäre also
logisch zu erwarten dass all diese
öffentlichen gelder in grüne energie
projekte elektroautos und ähnliche
innovation fließen nicht wahr das
könnten sie auch wenn brüssel einen
geeigneten und reale funktionstüchtigen
kontrollmechanismus für die verwendung
der milliarden eingerichtet hätte aber
unsere gute uche hat beschlossen darauf
zu vertrauen dass die politiker der
einzelnen mitgliedsländer schon wissen
wie man verantwortungsvoll mit geld
umgeht
in spanien zum beispiel haben sie
bereits beschlossen ein teil des geldes
wirst du grüne nachhaltige digitale
dynamische und 2.0 projekte wie dieses
zu verwenden die spanische regierung
wird eine milliarde für die sanierung
von öffentlichen gebäuden bereitstellen
erinnerst du dich noch an die ein
schienenbahn aus den simpsons nun im
moment fühlt sich europa mit 1 schienen
bahnen das heißt projekte die
wirtschaftlich keinen sinn machen musste
spanien seine gebäude wirklich so
dringend renovieren ist das wirklich der
beste weg um den klimawandel zu
bekämpfen oder eher ein weg um die
taschen der besitzer großer baukonzern
zu füllen die sich natürlich wiederum
sehr gut mit den politikern verstehen
was wir damit sagen wollen all dieses
von der politik an ihre freunde
verteilte geld wird all jenen
unternehmern und bürgern stil die dinge
erfinden verbessern und herstellt die
sich auf einem markt als das erste
angebot durchsetzen müssen und dass bei
dieser gigantischen summe über
generationen hinweg von der leyens logik
lässt sich mit den satz halt die klappe
und nicht mein geld zusammen fassen sie
geht sogar noch will davor als beiden
immerhin brauchen die usa eine
infrastruktur noch dringender als europa
hier geht es jedoch eindeutig nicht nur
darum geld um zu verteilen und
auszugeben nur um des geldausgebens
willen
[Musik]
und ich denke dass ihr versteht warum
wird dies so scharf kritisieren es geht
nicht nur darum dass all dieses geld
nicht den innovativsten und
effizientesten unternehmen zukommen wird
sondern an jene welche die besten
beziehungen zu den regierenden haben das
heißt vor allem an die großkonzerne und
amigo firmen in europa wird ist dadurch
weiterhin an innovativen und
wachstumsstarken unternehmen mangeln
denn der anreiz besteht nicht darin das
nächste google zu erschaffen und die
weltmärkte zu erobern sondern die
vorgaben einer öffentlichen
ausschreibung zu erfüllen um von der
europäischen geldmaschine maximal zu
profitieren außerdem geht es uns um die
fiskalischen und steuerlichen folgen von
all dem wir reden nicht nur über mehr
steuern das nehmen wir als gegeben hin
das größte problem ist dass all dies die
europäische zentralbank dazu zwingt
immer mehr geld zu drucken und das führt
zu inflation
die inflation in der eurozone steigt auf
4,9 prozent der höchste wert seit
einführung des euro so sieht's aus
willkommen in der ära der neuen
inflation in europa und den usa hatten
wir praktisch vergessen was inflation
ist in den nächsten jahren werden wir
uns daran gewöhnen müssen dass unser
geld egal ob angespart oder in form von
gehalt monat für monat an kaufkraft
verlieren soll natürlich können
installationen die wir im jahr 2029
erlitten haben durch viele andere gründe
erklärt werden nicht nur durch
staatsausgaben aber es ist zu erwarten
dass er mit dieser inflation wenn die
richtung nicht geändert wird auf dauer
werden leben müssen das allerschlimmste
wir reden speziell in europa nicht nur
über inflation sondern über stagnation
das größte schreckgespenst der
volkswirtschaftslehre überhaupt
[Musik]
sande erich europa stagniert schon seit
jahrzehnten die größten europäischen
unternehmen sind heute dieselben wie vor
20 jahren und das ist ein problem es
entsteht einfach nichts neues mehr was
mit der welt mit amerika und asien
konkurrieren könnte wir haben es hier
mit nichts anderes zu tun als mit einer
zeitenwende einer zeitenwende die für
europäer noch sehr bitter und demütigen
sein wird bisher konnten sich die
europäer einer sehr stabilen wirtschaft
ohne inflation rühmen der ehemalige
kommissionspräsident jean claude juncker
war der klassische gemäßigte politiker
der kaum in den medien auftauchte er hat
nie irgendwelche größenwahnsinnigen
maßnahmen beschlossen und auch nicht
versucht die welt mit dem scheck punkt
der steuerzahler zu verändern seine
nachfolgerin ursula von der leyen steigt
hat in hand mit der neuen ezb chefin
christine lagarde in einem neue
wirtschafts logik ein die und überhaupt
nicht gefällt und ich hoffe dass er es
verstanden habt was groß diese damit
eingebrockt haben und warum von der
leyen in diesem jahr 2021 zweifellos
unsere nennt de wort verdient hat aber
wer wird unser dritter preisträger seien
nun hierbei sollten mittig wollen wir
euch ja immer eine erweiterte
perspektive bieten den blick über den
tellerrand des üblichen medien kreises
und dieser blick wird euch zeigen dass
wir trotz der hier präsentierten polit
versager beiden und von der leyen noch
immer auf einer insel der glückseligen
leben haltet euch lieber fest denn mit
unserem dritten preisträger wird so
deutlich ungemütlicher
der visual politik 2021 nt ward am loh
die meisten von euch haben
wahrscheinlich noch nie etwas von am loh
gehört aber andrés manuel lópez obrador
ist der präsident eines landes mit 130
millionen einwohnern welches
kaufkraftbereinigt sogar die zwölf
größte volkswirtschaft der welt ist die
rede ist von den vereinigten staaten von
amerika was um himmels willen hat also
der mexikanische präsident verbrochen
damit visual politik ihm einen seiner
heiß begehrten ntr wars des jahres 2021
verleiht nun herr lópez obrador ist
sozusagen ein absoluter totalausfall hat
im grunde nichts von dem was er als
präsident eines großen landes machen
sollte richtig gemacht nicht einmal das
wozu er sich selbst verpflichtet hat und
was er eigentlich als seine obersten
prioritäten proklamiert hatte wie auch
immer sie es betrachten am los
ergebnisse sind ein desaster und jeder
verteidigungsversuche seiner person
hätte mehr löcher als der
sprichwörtliche schweizer käse denn im
gegensatz zu seinen mit preisträgern
beiden und von der leyen geht es bei
seiner verfehlten politik nicht nur um
das geld und den wohlstand seiner
mitbürger sondern wortwörtlichen sinne
und ihr leben und ihren tod
[Musik]
mexiko alex seit jahren einen brutalen
kartell krieg und eine gewaltspirale die
so groß ist dass eine koproduktion von
quentin tarantino stanley kubrick und
francis ford coppola wie eine folge
teletubbies dagegen aussehen würde um
der einen eindruck zu verschaffen
die sechs gewalttätigsten städte der
welt die mit den meisten morgen pro
100.000 einwohnern liegen alle in mexiko
die rede ist von stella ja die cranach
war es julia tobago porto und in kanada
und urlaub mannschaft ist auch noch in
die top ten
mexiko ist zum epizentrum der
mörderischen gewalt weltweit geworden
josé antonio ortega präsident des
bürgers für öffentliche sicherheit und
strafjustiz sieben der zehn mörderischen
städte der welt liegen also in mexiko
wir reden hier über ein land mit mehr
als 25.000 morgen und tötungsdelikten
pro jahr natürlich ist nicht nur am loh
dafür verantwortlich die kriminalität
erschüttert mexiko seit mindestens 15
jahren in großem umfang als andy
machtkampf hat ein zerrüttetes land mit
jährlich mehr als 520 toten und fast
50.000 spurlos verschwunden würde vor
aber warte denn das entbindet ihn nicht
von der ganzen schuld
haben muss die verantwortung dafür
übernehmen dass eines seiner großen
wahlversprechen genau darin bestand das
land zu befrieden zu diesem zweck setzt
der eine neue strategie um die politik
der umarmungen nicht der kugel ja du
hast richtig gehört tatsächlich war eine
seiner ersten aktionen die der präsident
nach seinem wahlsieg tat die
organisation von friedens foren im
ganzen land eine aktion der übrigens
aufgrund von protesten der gewaltopfer
selbst wieder eingestellt hat seitdem
besteht seine politik nur noch aus einem
chaotischen hin und her ohne klare
vorstellungen und die opferzahlen dieser
politik explodieren unterdessen hat in
den ersten 30 monaten der regierung
wurden mehr als
86.000 tötungsdelikte registriert eine
erschreckende bilanz die ident die haare
zu berge stehen lassen würde und die
ihnen so sehr an us auch lernen markt
zum präsidenten mexikos mit der
historisch schlechtesten kriminalitäts
bilanz überhaupt macht man wird sich an
diese regierung erinnern weil sie
kriminelle nicht strafrechtlich verfolgt
maria elena morena direktoren von causa
in kommunen aber wenn du dachtest das
allein sei schon ein tragischer feldern
passt lieber auf denn die kriminalität
ist bei weitem nicht der einzige
schwachpunkt dieses präsidenten
[Musik]
ein weiteres großes versprechen bloß
bezog sich auf den energiesektor und
insbesondere auf die erdölbranche
hannover sprach die glorreichen tage von
pemex mexikos historischer staatliche
ölgesellschaft wiederherzustellen einen
giganten dem es in den letzten
jahrzehnten immer schlechter ging wir
sprechen von einem unternehmen das bis
zu den augenbrauen im schuldensumpf
steckt und immer weniger öl fördert aber
mit andrés manuel lópez obrador sollte
sich das alles ändern so zumindest seine
vollmundigen wahlversprechen es ist erst
drei jahre her dass dieser präsident an
die macht kam und die frage ist glaubst
du dass er mit diesem vorhaben
erfolgreich war okay du hast
wahrscheinlich die antwort wenn wir ihm
schon ein lte wort verpassen aber wie
soll man schaffte es selbst die größten
pessimisten noch negativ überraschen
denn die ergebnisse seine politik gehen
genau in die entgegengesetzte richtung
unter applaus amtszeit hat die
verschuldung von pemex alle rekorde
gebrochen während die erdölförderung
ungebremst bergab geht als am loh an die
macht kam produzierte die mexikanischen
ölgesellschaft 1,8 millionen barrel
heute liegt die zahl bei 1,6 millionen
in einer welt mit immer weiter wachsende
nachfrage und explodierenden
energiepreisen und alles deutet darauf
hin das ist nicht viel besser werden
wird erschwerend kommt hinzu dass am
lungen die liberalisierung des
energiemarktes die sein vorgänger
durchgesetzt hatte rückgängig macht
wodurch viele private projekte ins
stocken geraten wie du siehst scheint es
als stünden wir vor einem weiteren mega
fällt aber wenn du denkst wir wären mit
am loh fertig wirst du dich gewaltig
denn wir könnten auch über seinen umgang
mit der pandemie sprechen mexiko ist ein
relativ junges land nur sieben prozent
der bevölkerung sind über 65 jahre alt
und ihr alle wisst sind gerade die
älteren am meisten durch das corona
virus gefährdet trotzdem hat mexiko die
fünfthöchste zahl von todesfällen durch
kurven sind in der welt zu verzeichnen
ja okay ich weiß relativ gesehen gibt es
länder die noch schlechter abgeschnitten
haben aber mexiko ist viel schlechter
dran als der durchschnitt niederländer
mit ähnlicher demographie und
einkommensniveau und obwohl der
handelskrieg zwischen china und den usa
mexiko zu einem sehr attraktiven
standort für viele große multinationale
unternehmen gemacht hat und trotz der
rekord überweisungen wie ins land
fließen kommt die wirtschaft nicht in
schwung und erholung verläuft langsamer
als erwartet etwas bei dem übrigens die
antikapitalistische agenda des
präsidenten nun ja nicht gerade
hilfreich ist denn wieder einmal große
überraschung hat sozialismus nicht dazu
geführt dass der wohlstand aller
zugenommen hat so dass alle gleich arm
wurden na ja einige halt noch etwas
hermanos fatale politik hat dazu geführt
dass die zahl der menschen in armut und
extremer armut seit seiner
machtübernahme dramatisch gestiegen ist
also ein weiteres großes unerfülltes
versprechen
so und jetzt kommt das große wunder
leider kein gutes wunder sondern ein
sehr trauriges eines welches den glauben
in die intelligenz der menschen nicht
gerade gestärkt denn so überraschend ist
auch klingen mag und trotz allem was wir
gesehen haben umfragen zufolge ist am
nach wie vor recht beliebt sie ist hier
an umfrage am loh erreicht 62 prozent
zustimmung in seinem dritten jahr als
präsident also was soll ich dir noch
sagen einstein hatte recht wahrlich
keine guten aussichten für das jahr 2022
der kampf noch ein langer sein und wir
von visual politik sind bereit ihn zu
kämpfen denn wenn du für etwas einstehen
dann ist es unabhängigkeit und
meinungsfreiheit weshalb lópez obrador
frau und präsidentin von allein und
präsent beiden diese rtl vox des jahres
2021 habt euch redlich verdient
[Musik]
und das meint ihr war unsere auswahl
gelungen und gerecht oder fallen euch
andere bessere preisträger an wie immer
sind auf eure meinung zu diesem thema
schon gespannt aber egal wie viel
kopfschmerzen uns die politik auch
bereiten mag das leben ist viel mehr als
das und in diesem moment verbringst du
wahrscheinlich ein paar tage mit seinen
ligen am ende des tages ist dies ihr das
wichtigste glücklich zu sein denn wenn
du die zeit mit ihnen menschen und
dingen verbringst du dir wichtig sind
daher danken wir euch dass er dieses
jahr so viel zeit mit uns verbracht und
damit unsere herzen gelernt habt ich
wünsche euch allen im namen des gesamten
politik teams ein gutes jahr 2022 hoffe
dass euch dieses video special gefallen
hat was ja gibt es bitter ein leichtes
mit euren freunden vergesst nicht dass
aber mit köpfchen und keines unserer
videos meister verpassen unterstützt
unsere arbeit bitte auch mit einer
kleinen spende über den link in der
beschreibung unter diesem video was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]